so this talk I didn't make this talk for
this session but it's one that I wrote
for a keynote for pi day to Berlin but
it covers there's a core section in
there that I think is something that
I've only recently come to understand
about what it is I find to be so special
about our PI data sort of community and
so it's in the middle of a section on
this talk about rethinking open source
how many of you have been using open
source for some time and are reasonably
conversant with the idea of open source
and Michael all right
I think actually it's it's high time for
us to rethink what open source really is
or what are some of its most essential
elements in order to be able to carry it
forward into a cloud future so these are
topics that we all see in here about
right in the open source community
there's burnout there's many things
people try to do with donations there's
the dip jar thing down on the unfocused
table and of course there's the question
of exploitation where cloud company was
able to use all this open source
software they might give some back
actually they might actually be able to
for instance I think in the case of
Amazon's [ __ ] service like I think they
might have more tabs on it then [ __ ]
has on their enterprise offering and
that's okay I guess or is it you know
and if it's not ok what's the principle
what are the underlying principles that
we say that's actually not ok or
something that's been lost in that
process and then and of course in
response I don't know how many people
here seen this but the the some of these
companies have adopted new licenses for
their open source software so they're
not really what we would consider in the
traditional open source kind of family
of things so you know makes me sad sad
emoji and so in order to go through all
the slides I have on this we have to go
ludicrous speed so I'm going to talk a
little fast but first topic is open
source so some people you know are
familiar with this debate of is it open
it does open me free and if it's free is
a free beer free speech right does open
mean I can read the source code well how
many of you use Syfy how many people
here have used Syfy how many have you
ever read the sci-fi source code the
entirety of it the entirety of it right
even 50
scent of it right I would challenge
anyone to be 50% of it because if you go
and look at it that's a crap ton of code
and there's ninety four lines of MATLAB
for whatever reason well travel is not
here but we'd ask them if you were here
what that is all about but the point is
we're kidding ourselves
if we say open means I can read the code
because when you read the code is when
something breaks and you're like is it
me or is the library right but at that
point that's only when it breaks if it
works you're never reading the code
right so it is does kind of mean free
and I always have the option I reserve
the option to go and look at what's
broken in it if I do something funky
with it this open meaning it's open to
new contributions right like if you have
a problem you can fix your problem well
thanks I could have done that anyway
like what is it so like what's the
what's the thing here because just
because open source doesn't mean that
they're gonna accept my changes in fact
they may see my change to say oh yeah
you know what we don't want to do that
our library should never do that that's
a screwed up use case never you're like
whoa it was actually okay for a little
bit right so that can happen too or does
it mean that you're actually open to
ideas because open to pr's is not the
same as open to ideas right and so the
point of this is just to get people
thinking a little to get some juices
flowing early in the morning about the
idea that open source is not just about
licenses it's actually for me it's about
empowering communities and powering
people to innovate so it actually has a
really wonderful way of aligning the
users and the developers right the
innovators who are making things they
get instant feedback from people doesn't
mean they're gonna take all their
feedback but they can have the route a
venue for feedback so it's really
important you know there's so much
discussion of a source I don't see many
people talking about this aspect of it
because even on Hacker News which is of
course a very narrow slice of the world
but a hacker news on reddit wherever
else it comes down to a lot of times is
it licenses well if the OSI has approved
this license then it's a guy I guess
it's open source no that's not
necessarily I mean that's technically
true but doesn't really achieve what we
want to achieve with this and the reason
why I think this is a really important
thing for us to think about is because I
think the Python community the open
source stuff we do here we have the
ability to actually take these principal
and move them for in a different way so
the thing that's interesting is that
everyone should keep in mind is that
code code actually is about api's right
there's few and fewer projects that are
just giant monolithic things even
tensorflow where I which is a giant
monolith from it was dropped as a giant
code drop from Google it's got a ton of
internal API a tunnel of extension api's
and what I unfortunately this is this is
a kind of a weird point but younger devs
I don't think remember the days of
Microsoft when we had to pay for
libraries and SDKs you had to pay like
it costs five ten thousand dollars have
access to all of the SDKs develop
everything on Windows that's what it
used to look like we've gone through a
period where the web took over
everything and now people just use cloud
services but if you are chained to using
certain ApS in the cloud service you're
essentially getting nickel and dimed
it's a death by a thousand cuts of the
exact same model right it doesn't matter
you can use a pile of open source from
this github repo and that repo and
everything else if to actually make your
thing work at all you're out $200 a
month to Amazon if that's the only way
you could possibly do it right so you're
still that the chains it's like an
invisible fence versus like hard iron
shackles to the wall of Microsoft and
Oracle but it's still it's still a thing
so this this last point is something
that people should definitely be aware
of because code and common pieces of
code turn into api's like the panas api
and whatnot commercial players can use
fake open source like all faux ofö
panned source they can establish these
standards that benefit only their
platform and so it's hard for someone to
make a standard for like of an Amazon or
a Google or an Oracle to make a standard
that only runs on their thing these
people like well if I use that then if I
speak that language if I put that little
feature set in my brain that I'm only
ever able to think on Oracle's cloud or
on Amazon's various things but if they
take one that already exists and they
slot in underneath it something that's
compatible and it's like whoa it's this
stuff I already know how to do and now
it's just really convenient to do over
here
and eventually it expands and what
Microsoft used to call that the strategy
was the embrace extend extinguish
strategy and that's essentially what's
happening to the open source API is that
we've established in the PI data space
in fact when Travis you know yesterday
he he was winching a little about
tensorflow
you know the fact that they are going
and trying to replace certain kinds of
numpy api's without working with the
numpy working with the Napa community
that's an element of this and and it's
not that they're trying to actively be
evil they're just corporations being
corporate they have a technology
strategy they need to get things done
their developers engineer's program
managers have KPIs they need to hit by
the quarter and that's just what they're
gonna do why would they slow down for
the community to sit there and argue on
a mailing list about some other stuff
over here right so it's not that there's
a manifest evil like dr. evil sitting
there saying we will destroy all
open-source its hey this is cool there's
a bunch of free users here we just match
this API built cool more stuff and
they'll use our stuff and now I get
bonus right it's a lot of people making
short-term decisions with no regard to
the thing that they're now destroying so
that's the accidental extend and
extinguish that's happening so in
response the immune response from
certain other players has been you know
pretty immediate but but when they do
this the thing to be aware of what I'm
talking about this this extend
extinguish about open ap is is not the
same as [ __ ] and Redis fight against
Amazon in the case of Redis in the case
of and I have a lot of respect for for
the engineers and the businesses and
everything but what they have is a
business model problem it's not an open
source problem because in both these
cases 99% of the source code even though
is open source is written by the people
directly employed by those companies
right the source code is open sourced as
a business loss leader decision and it's
that's a business model problem you
deliver some of these lost leader Amazon
took it said thank you take this
community in run with it you have a
business model problem that's not a
general challenge to open source but
this stuff over here this hijacking of
open communities that is a problem for
open source these are two different
kinds of things and the way I see this
the way I would articulate this very
succinctly is that stable open API are
actually a Commons they're a very
valuable thing so in economic theory we
talk about Commons which our utilities
it's very valuable that's basically what
they call
shelling point or something else like
that basically this idea that we're all
better if we work together here rather
than each of us trying to build every
single thing up from the ground up
ourselves it's just a much more
efficient use of resources so it's a
market between the users the maintainer
--hz and the innovators and those are
three different classes the maintainer
czar there to make sure that the thing
keeps working and that it avoids bit rot
and and slowly evolve it
innovators take it and make it do
something radically different do
something really great but they're able
to be accelerated in that they don't
have to go from ground to 30,000 feet
they can start 20,000 feet and go to
30,000 feet and that's really cool so
it's very it's a different set of
concerns there and all of these are
about preserving choice for the user so
user can say I'm gonna use what's here
today and I'm gonna keep using it for
five years and if no one else is around
to maintain it I can go and hire
consultants in I can hire my own
developers to go maintain it because I
have access to all the source code it's
all right there but if the user says hey
you know what I want to be bleeding-edge
supervillainy on I want the latest
release even before it's released I can
do that too it gives a lot of choice to
different users into innovators it's
wonderful is a tremendous significant
value for human society that we can do
this so then if there is this concept of
you know something is not just open or
just closed there's scales of openness
right if it's open but the only
developers in the world answer questions
on it work at one company then it's kind
of open but kind of not if it's open but
there's no one maintaining it but anyone
everyone uses it then it's also kind of
open and if it ever breaks a lot of
resources will flood in to fix it like
open SSL right but that's what every
kind of open so this concept of
non-binary openness is sort of something
I put out there but I think it's
important for everyone to think about
open source in a very intentional way
and not just say is this open source is
it not but rather thing about what
aspects of this are actually open what
is it that I care about when I engage
with this open source thing and I would
say that a lot of people in our
community they they use it well I'll get
to that in the next a little bit but
from a material like business decision
process point of view these are the
things that I would say matter to a
business right as I'm thinking about
should I use this piece of software take
a dependency on it for my project it's
around these kinds of things so let's
talk about software then because this
is all open-source and almost everything
I talk about here applies not just well
this applies to software but many other
things I talked about in this section
apply to open source hardware templates
open source many kinds of things but if
we talk about open software itself open
source software the there's a point that
sometimes is missed by people because
you know we all know that Linux is open
source Emacs is open source vim docker
the Apache web server all these things
are open source and these are August
pieces of open source software from the
90s I've been around for a very long
time and people of course don't really
question their use of these things at
this point and usually they were built
by devs to scratch dev itches and
usually they were they're designed to
solve like infrastructure software kinds
of things so a line at Microsoft about
open source used to be that open source
solves well-known problems right I need
a text editor
I'm Richard Stallman I will make my own
I need an extensible text editor right
or we need to go and do these bits of
orchestration I don't like to use puppet
and chef and these other things and a
bunch of VMware I'm gonna go do my own
thing I'll make docker
alright so people do these things
because they're solving problems that
are fairly well-defined but in the
Python and the PI data sci-fi world this
has actually been a little bit different
the open source here was built to
scratch itches not of software devs but
of postdocs assistant professors of
researchers and they're actually having
to do it because they can't get CS
people to solve their problems for them
right that's actually a really
interesting thing because over here this
is solving well-known problems in both
cases people are scratching their own
itch but in in both cases they're doing
there's a different motivation a lot of
times here it's for the look at what I
did I can get brag about it on Hacker
News and over here it's like crap I
didn't my work done and also it's kind
of really cool a lot of fun right and
there's maybe a cool community that's
starting to give form around it and I'll
do it but in the 90s and the 2000s a lot
of the stuff grew up around this it's
like for us too we don't have access to
a large giant pool of developers we have
do it ourselves and thanks to Python and
thanks to some of the
design decisions there and the early
groundwork laid in that in that
ecosystem wouldn't go and do these
things and that's really awesome so I
think it's really important all of that
is to say that when we talk about open
source we should be very very
intentional in distinguishing between
open source for commoditization versus
open source for innovation so classic
infrastructure open source stuff tends
to solve these well-known problems but
these numerical ones are solving
advanced problems that seems like nobody
the world cares about until they give
rise to like machine learning in AI
which everyone that all sudden cares
about and in both cases though open
source facilitates an open marketplace
so the mark the cost of maintenance you
can trade that off against the upside
the risk of future innovation and what I
mean by that that's kind of a lot to
unpack in that sentence but if you have
a thing that works you can go and say
well this works and I don't make many
changes to it it'll continue working but
for me to do this other really cool
feature I'm going to make a bunch of
changes to it so a very classic example
is a map pot lid right you can't do
interactive map plot lib through the
browser although there have been tools
to do that people have thrown a little
things out there but to really do it as
well as bouquet or plotly requires a
deep refactor of matplotlib now if
you're poor Thomas and Thomas guys
always maintained their do you want to
break millions of people's code and
possibly get there before everyone just
uses whatever tableau looker Amazon
charting service or do you just say well
let's just not break the world and let's
let have everyone's stuff still work
right that's a that's a trade off every
single software dab of every library
always has to make all the time and in
this case you can actually have an
honest trade off you can actually have
other people the community say will
maintain these bits we want this stuff
one or a factor this will put our time
in to do this or someone else is gonna
do a crazy year-long thing and come
around say hey look what I did and
actually I did it for you already right
so there's a really cool marketplace
around that and that gets this network
intelligence to kind of explore the
possibility space it's a really cool
thing so the PI data and the Syfy
innovation community I would say this is
what I was saying in my keynote earlier
the thing that's so different about us
this sort of thing is so different about
this community that's wonderful to keep
in mind
is that it's been pursuing the art of
the possible for twenty years and it's
been doing it with basically minimal
resources minimal volunteer resources it
has pursued the art of the possible and
all of the successful projects that I've
seen blossom in this space have a few
defining characteristics that made it's
made them play well with each other they
having reasonable the leadership is a
really important thing playing well with
others we have to deliver actual value
quickly and we we have to sort of limit
the scope a little bit so it can plug
into other things well we don't do here
is invent the world hijack other
projects users etc etc etc right these
are actual things that that people care
about when we talk about hey is this a
good project how is this project doing
with these other relative these other
ones and I would say this collaborative
community has out innovated and better
leverage human labor than capitalism by
far the example I like to give is that
not anymore but as of like you know a
few years ago I could have fit the
entire maintainer community of numpy
Saipan and pandas well numpy Syfy at
least a map hall Lib into my minivan
it'd be a little tight but fit them in
my minivan and if we strap west to the
top of it then we get pandas and that
would be basically billions of dollars
of value that's being added to the
global economy every day in a minivan I
cannot think of a single a single other
instance where we have that kind of
leverage of human labor and human human
knowledge there are a few lone geniuses
you know the famous JFK quote about
Thomas Jefferson dining alone all that
all that kind of grandstanding aside
actual concrete getting stuff shipped
that people use that like does MRI
processing looks at the burning of the
Amazon puts Rockets up in space you know
all these other kinds of things like the
actual amount of trading the amount of
stuff that happens on the on the
software infrastructure being delivered
by that mini man full of Homo Sapien
mass this innovation community has far
better done this far better than any
other mechanism far better than any
other organizing principle that's the
thing we need to preserve and understand
oh yeah awesome right so what do
businesses value an open source though
so we've done this but what are they
value in it
it's not actually about the cost of
software the truth is for most
businesses the cost of software is small
relative the cost of the people relative
to business risk and innovation risk and
all these other kinds of things and so
what they really really care about that
I've come to understand is they want to
avoid lock-in they want to be the
hardest innovation but they want to be
able to have control over their own
destiny about when they adopt certain
things what's what's gonna happen
everyone wants control right it's true
of individuals it's true of large
organizations but what is the open
source community value a whole different
set of things right it's a gift economy
it's a sharing economy right if you if
you show up in you know you go to Saipan
next fall next summer and you give a
talk you know like here's a pile of code
I've been working on for ten years in
isolation and it's awesome people really
Wow
you shouldn't release a little bit
earlier because this thing that thing
the other thing like no single person is
smarter than all the other people right
so participating having pride in what
you do so like shipping a bunch of crap
is not good but but you want to
participate you want to be a vulnerable
say well this is not perfect yet but
here's our ideas and here's some cool
stuff and in a sense the software
artifact is almost a byproduct at some
point the stable running development
community is the important thing now it
is the utility for the end users at the
end of the day someone's got to be able
to like you know conned install the
package and have it work but but really
what's really valuable is having this
stability and predictability efficiency
in the development process itself
they only maintain stuff ship stuff and
still have be open to innovation really
really hard so I think as open-source
communities mature the important thing
is not just can they play the song can
you put a finger on the right places on
the fingerboard to play the notes but
how well all these all these instruments
play well how well they play together is
really really important that's that's
almost as important as the music itself
if we're today if we're to zero out the
repositories for all of the major like
all the num focused projects or to zero
them out I bet that we could rebuild in
some period of time I take time to
rebuild it but just with those same
people who are the maintainer --zz they
could rebuild high quality stuff in a
shockingly short amount of time but if
you were to give that same task of
rebuild the entire num focus pie data
stack
any other group of developers okay how
wealthy you are I don't care if you're
the most wealthiest company in the world
a Facebook or Google or Microsoft is
great at shipping software I don't think
you deliver the same kind of thing that
this community can deliver that is the
same properties of being well maintained
open to innovation and you know well
maintained in the future like that is a
really really amazing thing actually
that a volunteer community Orchestra
becomes the the best orchestra in the
world that's amazing actually but what
they both miss is that software isn't
code software is a relationship all
right
it's your code saw me someone else's
problem and there's a lot of words here
I'll give people a chance to read it my
wallet texts so I think that if we're to
talk about software communities it the
emphasis should be on community as
opposed to the software the software's
the ancillary thing of this community
produces but a really important thing is
the community that produces that
software so the way I would talk about
is like a river so the river is more
than any drop of water you cannot take a
teaspoon and scoop a little teaspoon of
the Mississippi and say I've got the
Mississippi right the Mississippi is
this thing it's actually a particular
flow through the landscape if the entire
Mississippi if you got rid of the entire
every drop of water and it started
raining again at The Fountainhead you
tell you get the Mississippi back and so
this idea that we have a community of
practitioners of thinkers of innovators
of coders of users actually power users
they all define a landscape of
possibilities and so this idea that
everyone in the business world thanks to
Bill Gates they value software as an
artifact that artifact just a little cup
of water out of a river the river is
actually much more fundamental and the
river is there because of this flow and
so this process view and a people
oriented view of software communities is
really the way I've gotten to come
around to thinking about this stuff and
the way the community flows how does the
Mississippi grow and change if you've
seen really cool time-lapse videos of
how the river deltas and estuaries
change over time
it's beautiful it's just an absolutely
amazing thing to see we have the same
thing here happening in the world of
software that essentially these
communities explore alternative the
little real let's turn into streams turn
into the future of the river and that's
really the right way to think about the
communities and how we explore
possibility space so when we look at the
health of a community you can look at
github stars you look at number of
commits per day and all other stuff but
really there's I think the measures are
more thermodynamic and more physical in
nature based it on these processes the
other thing is that open-source software
again to my dings on Bill Gates was a
very smart guy but he really I don't
know how people here ever read how many
of you read his letter to hobbyists back
in like the 70s anyone yeah so back in
this back in the day people did not
treat software as a thing it was a
because the hardware the computer was a
super valuable thing the software was
like an instruction manual tucked in the
glove compartment it's like it's kind of
cool but who cares Bill Gates saw the PC
revolution coming and people were
starting to pirate they were just
copying code all over the place and he's
like whoa hold on so he wrote a letter
it's called the letter if you want to
Google it's the letter to hobbyists from
Bill Gates he were an angry little
letter saying look if you all just keep
copying our software then we won't be
able to be a viable business in this
whole industry like basically he
conceived of the software industry by
calling software property by drawing a
line in the sand and saying those bits
on that floppy disk or on that tape
those bits are my bits and if you take
them you need to pay me again for my
bits but the fact of the matter is
philosophically metaphysically software
is unknown etta physical basis to define
software as property you can actually go
and look at this is one example usufruct
is one aspect that people attribute to
what property ownership means it's the
use of the deriving utility deriving
value from the use of a thing but many
other things the right to destroy the
right to mutate all these are other
properties of prop there aspects of what
we call property rights almost none of
them pertain to software so software's
unpretty and thus it's intrinsically
anti rival list that means if you go and
use software and I use the same software
there's no conflict if you eat a banana
I can't eat that banana if you build a
house and a gorgeous view I can't build
a house and
same place without blocking your view
right but software is intrinsically anti
rival risks and that confuses the out of
most economic engines because it cut
economics is all about scarcity and so
the the last 30 years has been about how
do we build how do we couple the the
engines and our reasoning about scarce
economic models to an intrinsically anti
rival risks unpretty
thing and that's done through software
licensing it's done through I'll give
you a heart-wrenching story yesterday
actually I got back to my house after
being here in the morning and my
daughter I walked in and my wife wasn't
like in the shower something like that
my daughter was on the tablet and she
there's a little paint-by-numbers app
she's been using and there's a little
there's um we don't pay for it so it's a
little adware thing but one of the
things that they give you these little
color bombs so you take the color bomb
and you splash it and just automatically
colors a bunch of the picture it's super
cool but there's only like two color
bombs available and you have to pay for
the app to get more and my daughter
accidentally tapped it with her thumb
and she was crying cuz she used one of
her two color bombs now how many people
here know how to code that color bomb
thing and how many of you know what it
would take how much more effort and
sweat it would take to take that one
color bomb and make it a million or
infinite number of color bombs right
software is infinite the things we can
do with software is so amazingly
powerful and yet at every single step of
the way we've gated it we've checked
pointed it we've limited it
we've made it finite and scarce we've
made little five-year-olds cry on a
Saturday morning because we got to get
our dollar that's the amazing thing and
what they opened the reason why the pie
data the open source community has been
able to out-compete out-innovate so many
other large masses of people is that
sharing increases value in generative
economies and generative dynamics
sharing increases value you ever imagine
going to a book club or Reading Club
reading circle and saying well I read
the book I'm not I tell you my idea
unless you tell me yours I'll rate your
idea on a scale of one to ten and I'll
only give you my ideas that are within
5% of your idea that's crap
we go to a Reading Club because we share
ideas with each other because we get
better we love hearing other people's
ideas that's that you have sharing
increasing value so we're sort of peak P
wagging here because I'm quoting my own
tweets okay so but there's a pin tweet
for a while for me which is that
Conway's law how many people here are
familiar with Conway's law few people
Conway's law said that he was consultant
who studied software systems he was
hired to study some software projects
back in like the 70s or 80s and he
coined this law that said that based on
what he saw the architecture of a piece
of software resembles the communication
architecture of the organization that
produced it so if you build a piece of
software and you say well I need I've
this this this I'm gonna hire a group to
do this and other group works on this
part of the project and other group
works on this this software will be
architected in a tripartite way if you
have five groups five teams that do
different things your software
architects are solving the same problem
will have five components to it so
software the architecture of the
software mirrors the information
architecture or the information
communication patterns of the people
that develop it and so the flip of that
then DJ microbeads whoever he or she is
said that look if software systems mimic
the organizational structure of
organizations then innovations in
software must come from new
organizational structures boom so
obvious so obvious and yet so incredibly
deep because it means that if we want
software to stop being broken
we must stop having broken organizations
that build that software right code is a
cultural artifact and the culture of
this community that has produced these
amazing code innovations that's the
thing we must preserve not how to
relicense some of this crap so that you
can go in the cloud if someone doesn't
you know partition it off and all other
stuff it's how do we defend the culture
that produced the stuff so that's my
last part of my talk is the community
itself so Clay Shirky
wrote a book called here comes everybody
where he talks about crowdsource
crowdsourcing and a number of different
things in the world of course that a
crowdsource we all know them Wikipedia
things like that Kickstarter in a sense
is kind of an IndieGoGo these are
crowdsourcing a little bit
and the first thing he says there's four
stages of collaboration the first one is
what it calls me first collaboration and
I won't get into details of all this
other stuff but but I'll just lay out
the the four that's here I think in the
interest of time yeah and the the part
here is that you got to build something
that kind of works for yourself then you
got to actually have a place where
people can come together and talk to you
about it and learn about it and then you
actually have collaboration where groups
actually come together with a shared
purpose and what's really fascinating
about this is that he did not write this
as a lecture on open source software but
he did actually call this that it's
often characterized at people wanting to
fix a market failure because the reason
that we oftentimes collaborate is
because markets have failed to actually
solve the problem so work together to
overcome the market failure
Marcus represent a packaging of
solutions to maybe a previous
understanding of the problem not what
the new understanding is available on
our state is available and then the very
end and he says most groups do not get
to this at the very end you have
collective action which is when the
group actually cares about the group
itself the fate of the group as a whole
becomes important this is just a bunch
of people adding stuff to Wikipedia
because we don't all want a paper in
Carta online this is the Wikipedia
editors coming together and having a
conference every year twice a year
saying how do we make what competed
better how to defend the values of
Wikipedia right most people don't get to
this point and a really important part
of this is that there's a difference
between participation and labor they're
different when you go and you do some
stuff and get paid for it that's labor
and obviously if you're not you know an
indentured servant or a slave you
volunteered into that labor it was a
volunteer exchange of your labor for
dollars or some kind of a remuneration
but but participation is actually kind
of different participatory cultural
activity it gives you a voice in a
preserves your agency right and this is
kind of when when you're a contractor
right the definition the legal
definition of like a 10:09 contractor is
that they're told what to do but not how
to do it
right so I need that sighting fixed I
need this deck built get a contractor in
I need this website built get a
contractor in you're not gonna go and
stand over the shoulder tell them how
they need to do it they're doing it but
that's also not participation it's just
an example of even in labor law we
separate and we put some bounds around
when people have voice and when people
have agency over how something is done
so when you accept other people into
this participation culture you have to
have trust with them so cultures and
communities arise communities of
collaboration arise when trust can
develop between people and then now
we're all participating in trustful way
all of you attending this conference you
are participating right how many of you
are here because your employer said you
must attend or we're gonna fire you
anybody I'll talk to your boss if they
told you right so there is some element
of participation here because you care
about this stuff
that's participation and it's not
absolute just like the openness it's not
binary zero one open closed
participation of Labor we're all sort of
in the middle and you know people talk
about effective labor and versus anomie
where it's just labor I mean even in the
labor side there's a lot of stuff and
participation likewise there's many
different types of participation all of
you here are participating although
obviously you hope to learn things that
then apply to your job so it's it's a
you know it's a mix of these things but
ultimately for a collaborative culture
for cowboy collaboration culture to to
turn into this participatory mode you
have to have a way from be able to
develop trust with each other and I
think a challenge that people have today
and we see this in different I think I
see different shades of this manifesting
in our ecosystem and in our
conversations it's really hard to trust
corporations and brands they're not
vulnerable they have entire large PR
departments to make sure that there's no
[ __ ] in the armor they're not
vulnerable brands are there for you to
consume brands are there for you to
consume their stories about themselves
if you start developing a story about
them on Twitter they will come in and
engage with you to change that story
right brands are there to be consumed
not to invite participation invite trust
and that's what people don't trust
corporate participation in these kinds
of things
so trust still we're hairless primates
300,000 years off the of the savanna we
still tied trust to viewing each other
just spending time with each other
bumping elbows hugging right just
breaking bread with each other
Trust is still tied to individual
so I think what we have here the best
model I can think of for the PI data
community and the SyFy PI data you know
actually a Python community in general
is that of a community garden and people
have put a lot of labour into it but
they've all participated in tending the
garden and for a long time we've had
this honor box where it's here's a bunch
of free fruit
you don't become water it you don't have
to weed we come in and we do it because
we love gardening but here's some free
fruit enjoy and I think companies like
anaconda and Quan side we try to be like
the community cooperative little farm
store on the side of the farm we
understand how important it is to till
the soil and to water the plants and all
these things and we try to have an
easier way to buy an easier way to
participate for all the other
participants out there but what is not
appreciated or what is not um
when corporate players show up they
don't understand the magic that made
this garden grow they don't need to
reason about it because I say well
there's free fruit and the corporate
model is one of very direct linear
models that fit on spreadsheets right so
if this much water there's much nitrogen
there's much oxygen and as much sunlight
led to this much fruit we're gonna back
up and we're to pave a highway to it
back up our industrial farming equipment
build greenhouses put this much stuff in
pump it all in and we'll have ten times
amount of fruit right and that's not
actually how it works so that's the part
that's the education I'm trying to
impart to all of those folks they don't
they're not trying to destroy it it's
just their models of thinking about this
doesn't work and the reason and this is
the crux this is the golden part of this
talk is that all of us I think I would
say looking around here most of us come
from a Western tradition of thinking
which in modern Western modernity is
very focused on talking about goals
goal-oriented thinking how many of you
have ever been told to succeed in life
you must set good goals concrete goals
and work towards them I don't disagree
with that that's clearly true if I have
no goals would wander around aimlessly
right so having goals is good but what's
completely missed in the conversation we
do not stress this into people is that
it is just as important to live your
values and here's the really interesting
thing every single activity every single
object that you contemplate every
relationship you engage in can be viewed
from both of these
both of these dimensions both these
aspects if I have a car I can say this
car is a means it's a vehicle literally
a vehicle for me to get to the airport
for me to get to the grocery store for
me to get to school to get to work it's
an object
it helps me achieve my goals actually in
goal or into thinking we tend to
objectify other people processes and
actual objects but I can also look at
the car as a different thing I said wow
this car is a much better car than I had
before this car or this car is an
electric car and now I'm living my
values of environmentalism right or this
car is a second-hand car I'm buying used
cars because I have a value of frugality
right or this car is a brand shiny new
Beemer because my values that I you know
I really love money and you laugh this
is why also why people call Wall Street
soulless is there's a place that's
completely goal oriented and the only
value is to achieve numerical goals
those of us who work close to Wall
Street have been there or know people
who have been in that orbit you know the
type right there are people there's a
reason why New York the New York finance
scene changes you is because it
basically atrophies this part of your
humanity when we look at other people I
mean I have many of my employees here in
the room and I can say well these people
I have a goal-oriented post to them
right they have different job functions
and that's all great but it's extremely
important it is really bad for us to
view other people in a way that's blind
to values to shared values and living
shared values so the reason this these
are up here is because my friend Joe
Edelman runs thing called the human
systems Institute in Berlin and they
talk explicitly about this and he has a
much more a much better articulation of
this principle that in life we have just
in the Western world in particular and
in modernity we have just way over
emphasized one arm which is the goal or
into thinking and we've completely
de-emphasized the value based thinking
and the reason why this is important is
because for the PI data community
the thing that's differentiated about it
is not how much faster we ship software
and how much would better we've we've
leveraged human labor versus capitalism
it's actually the values are different
there are special values in this
community that have competitive driven
us this far by living our values this
community is actually outperformed not
by pushing harder
I mean if you go around and you ask all
the unfocused project leaders
what are your KPIs how well is your team
doing on the KPI so let's build a big
old Gantt chart and look at how you're
shipping maybe like oh I don't know man
you know but so-and-so just had a baby
so we take some time off so they can go
and take care of the kid right like that
the values we've lived have managed to
achieve goals better than if we were
just strict goal-oriented that
particular dynamic is the thing we need
to preserve now that being said we have
to be very intentional and thinking
about this in the world that's coming
where cloud is pervasive
sensors are everywhere scary ml and AI
models are gonna be turned on by people
have no idea what they mean to go and
make all sorts of decisions we can you
know bang our fists on the table all we
want to out bias and about all this
other stuff
it doesn't matter most the world is
numerically illiterate and they will
just believe what the Machine and black
box tells them they would do that
they're do that with Excel right people
have explained ability and AI I want
explain ability in Excel first
right and so this idea that we can we
that if we don't lean in and actually
Drive and extend the values of this
community then we're just going to be
eclipsed by more goal-oriented thinking
by how much how much more open-source
software can we ship and you already see
it a little bit like when you look at
github metrics there's not a ding on
github I'm just sort of talking about
this mentality of goal versus value
thinking when you look at github and
many people do they go to github to look
at the health of a project nowhere in
that discussion is it does the project
have a value statement how well do they
live their values can you imagine how
insane that would be if you went on to
the github tracker for like any of these
projects go to like MP MJS and say what
are the values of this project who wants
to do that and what I'll do it it'd be
interesting but what you'll find is a
bunch of geeks like what do you mean
values like yeah we want to be cool want
to do good work for your views I mean
they might even get to here's the values
where aren't you good work for users
we're having a maintainable service all
the stuff let's say you're not living
those values very well but you know at
the end of the day if projects don't I
always flip in a JavaScript ding in all
my talks yeah but the idea here is that
these projects we look at things like
number of downloads number of commits
release cadence number of developers and
all these other kinds of things and it's
great to have like diversity metrics
right how many new people are the
onboarding underrepresented folks and
all these other
the things that's all great but those
are all like that's very goal-oriented
approaches to what should be adding
values and values of inclusion values of
these you know values of service those
are the kinds of values that have
actually moved this community really
really far and if we don't defend those
values and we get fixate and wrapped
around goals we're gonna get eaten alive
and steamrollered by these big corporate
players who have a completely different
set of values and that's what
colonisation feels like by the way is
when someone else with different values
comes in and you may have the same
buildings you may eat the same foods
have the same holidays but you're
colonized because your values are not
different and that's the problem that I
see that's the conflict is the value
conflict between the open source
community and the corporate players so
for us to when we talk about who was it
that little was a lilly Lillian Lilly
had the question about project
leadership and in governance so I talked
about crossing the chasm in my in my in
my previous talk so when you were
talking to products crossing the chasm
is frequently talked about as go to
market so those of you who are in the
business role broader probably familiar
with this term we built this product now
what's our go-to-market how do we sell
it how do we package it how do we talk
about it and all these other things but
for projects that equivalent concept is
go to community and so to do that in the
early adopter stage it's about the tech
but to cross the chasm it should be
about your values and that's sorry for a
very long-winded answer to your question
from an hour ago but that's the answer
is that project leadership and
governance in the early stages should be
about the tech because that's how you
make yourself differentiated in the
world in a sense it is kind of a value
the technical values will always be
there we want certain kinds of technical
excellence we want certain kinds of
innovation and be open innovation things
like that but as you cross into this
other market the value should dominate
the conversation Elinor Ostrom is
probably the most storied thinker and
the most August thinker in the space
about Commons and
in most of the studies that she did
whether it was like you know Swiss sheep
farmers and past years that were Commons
all of her studies around Commons and
communities and things like that they
tended to be around Commons of scarce
resources in the physical world because
the physical world fundamentally is
rival Wriston scarce and so it's about
defending a scarce resource from rival
risk depletion right of all of us just
get our sheep to go eat as much grass as
possible then all of us are actually
hosts versus if we actually establish a
pattern right but innovation and
creation are not rival risks so what is
the Commons that needs defending right
because we because I already said
software value software if I take an
open-source repo I can go do whatever I
want to with it how does that stopping
you from doing anything there's no
there's no there's no rival risk there
I'm not taking anything from you can go
and make code to you can make a new
version of it I can make a new version
of it why you know is there is there a
thing there that needs defending from as
a Commons and there is and actually what
it is is detention and the time of the
developers because if every single one
of us goes in Forks Sify we've hurt all
of us because there's only so many
developers out there who could use the
next version of sci-fi and now they're
gonna spend their time either analysis
paralysis land or they're gonna say
screw all this I'll just stick with
MATLAB right or whatever but all of us
actually competing for the future there
is a cost to it it's not free we can't
innovate for free because if we want our
innovation get adopted we're competing
for a rival risk resource which is the
time attention of developers of the
developer community and and in this way
this is the danger of the foe
open-source sort of stuff from the cloud
vendors they're colonizing that Commons
they're taking it a wholesale so when I
talk about open source software and open
source awful community it's about what
is open openness is embodied in the
lived values of the community that's the
important thing
and those values need offending those
values will not be defended by big
corporate players I'm gonna try my
damndest over the next year several
years to convince to give condensed
versions of this talk for business heads
but basically to convince them that they
do they cannot call a nice
they need actually work well with and
show up as part of the community could
participate and share the values but at
the same time the community itself need
to start building antigens and building
some defensive awareness of the dynamic
that's happening these values will not
defend themselves you must all defend
them that's a talk
[Applause]